bonjour emmanuel dupil merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous dans la
matinale d'arreter france première
question pourquoi les talibans ou en
norvège pourquoi la norvège et avec qui
bon déjà la norvège a un long passé de
médiation internationale
ces ong sont très actives elles ont été
très actives en afghanistan et dans
d'autres zones de conflits et la norvège
se piquent d'un rôle de médiateur que
beaucoup de pays européens ne veulent
pas assumer un effet d'opportunité
pourquoi maintenant à ce qu'il ya une
urgence absolue - agences humanitaires
votre reportage le montre parfaitement
la moitié de la population est dans une
situation alimentaire aiguë un million
d'afghans qui ont moins de 10 ans sont
dans une
situation de famine aiguë et bien
évidemment la situation économique ne
s'est pas améliorée elle ad empiré
depuis la prise de pouvoir des talibans
donc à une urgence a essayé de faire
cette opération de séduction qu'il tente
de faire en norvège alors la norvège est
certes pas membre de l'union européenne
mais les membres de l'otan et elle peut
jouer cette jonction entre la gendarme
op 1 l'agent d'américains d'ailleurs tam
ouest le représentant spécial donc des
états unis pour le dialogue avec les
talibans c'est son titre
apprécié sera présent mais néanmoins il
faut avoir à l'esprit que les talibans
ne sont là que pour une seule raison
récupérer l'argent qu'ils jugent
illégitimes en encore entre les mains
des interlocuteurs qui vont avoir
l'allemagne france est allée les états
unis et surtout l'italie les talibans
avec par le biais de celui qui gère donc
la délégation celle qui dirige la
délégation amir khan route à qui le mit
les affaires étrangères réclament les
avoirs du précédent gouvernement qui ont
été gelés par les états unis ont été
gelés par les banques américaines par le
trésor américain 10 milliards d'euros
la question c'est que font-ils de cet
argent certainement pas pour apaiser les
douleurs et les affres de vos pièces
anciennes d'autant que l'aide
humanitaire ait gelé aussi depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans en
août dernier vous disiez la population
on a énormément besoin la norvège peut
jouer ce rôle de médiateur entre les
acteurs européens et m 15 alors qu'elle
est accusée de de cautionner finalement
ce pouvoir taliban s'est justifié déjà
il ya une dimension politique dans tout
ça c'est qu'il ya eu un changement de
gouvernement il ya quelques mois le
précédent gouvernement étaient un
gouvernement conservateur là c'est un
gouvernement social démocrate et donc
son goût lance de cette démocrate a
décidé ce que le précédent gouvernement
ne voulait pas faire c'est à dire
franchir ce pas non pas d'une
reconnaissance mais d'un dialogue direct
avec les talibans deuxième élément
les pays de l'union européenne
finalement voit d'un bon oeil le fait
que ce soit un pays non membre de
l'union européenne qui puisse accueillir
sa délégation en partant du principe que
l'union européenne veut absolument pas
ni se compromettent mais en même temps
ne peut pas faire comme si la situation
n'était pas gravissime l'hiver est rude
en afghanistan la population près de 24
à 25 millions d'afghans ont un besoin
immédiat d'assistante et des
d'humanitaires et puis surtout il ya une
pression qui est international si
l'union européenne où les pays
occidentaux ne produit pas cette aide
humanitaire d'autres ont proposé de le
faire la chine la russie par exemple a
livré déjà le mois dernier 36 mille
tonnes d aide humanitaire mais vous avez
raison de mentionner le fait que les
pays du voisinage
sont aussi un peu empêtré dans cette
dans cette coupe dans cette situation un
peu qui prête à confusion d'un côté ils
ne veulent pas discuter avec les
talibans mais en même temps ils sont ils
ont quand même la nécessité en tant que
pays voisin de ne pas laisser près de 39
millions d'afghans livre alors ça alors
qu'elle quelles garanties peuvent donner
les talibans justement les occidentaux
les etats-unis réclament des des actes
concrets après les paroles des talibans
pour dire qu'il respecterait les droits
humains quels qu'aient lequel d'actes
concrets concrètement pourrait-il donner
je crois qu'ils diront pas autrement que
ce qu'ils ont dit jusqu'à présent qu'ils
respecteront le droit des femmes qu'ils
procéderont à un changement
gouvernemental en enfants pratiquant
cette inclusion que nous appelons de
notre voeu en réouvrant les écoles ils
ont d'ailleurs promis de le faire à
partir de mars précisément
en coupant le cordon ombilical avec les
groupes armés terroristes et notamment
al qaïda est effectivement en promettant
de ne pas s'en prendre aux priorités le
problème c'est que ce ne sont que des
mots qui ne sont pas corrélées par des
actions alors que les talibans se
rendent en norvège plusieurs activistes
on est avocat des droits humains et
notamment des universitaires et des
femmes qui manifestaient dans les rues
de kaboul se sont vus arrêter quelques
heures avant que les talibans ne prenais
l'avion donc d'une certaine façon il ya
un discours que les talibans nous livre
et la réalité sur le terrain qui n'a
absolument pas changé depuis la prise de
pouvoir du 15 août dernier et
paradoxalement les talibans en norvège
vont discuter aussi avec des membres de
la société civile des exilés avons aussi
un et des femmes et des femmes mais ils
vont surtout discuter avec ceux qui ont
manifesté contre leur présence donc en
fait ce sera un dialogue de sourds et
encore une fois c'est peut-être un petit
peu notre cynisme qui veut que une fois
que les talibans ont dit un certain
nombre de vérités que nous voulons
entendre nous en nous en satisfaisant le
problème c'est que sur le terrain la
preuve est faite que ce n'est absolument
pas le cas merci beaucoup emmanuel
dupuis d'avoir répondu ce matin en
direct à nos versions sur rt france